uh you've seen the movie whiplash by any
chance yes
it seems like in a man's life
or it could be a woman's but i'm i don't
identify as a woman so i know the man
them the lyrics it's 20 20 bro but
my lived experience for now is that of a
man we'll see about tomorrow
and there is in the pursuit of
excellence
there's often a choice of
um some of the souls that must be
trampled are personal relationships
with humans in your life that you might
deeply care about it could be family it
could be friends
it could be loved ones of all different
forms
it could be the people that your
colleagues
that depended on you people who will
lose jobs because of the decisions you
make all this kind of stuff
it seems that that moment happens and
i'm not sure
that sacrifice is always the correct one
like to me the movie whiplash for people
haven't seen
a spoiler alert maybe i don't even know
if that movie has any
spoilers but there is a relationship
with a female
there's a student that's a drummer
that's pursuing excellence of this
particular
art form of drumming and he has
a brief fleeting relationship with a
female
and he also has an instructor that's
pushing him to his limits
in what appears to be awfully a lot like
a toxic relationship
and he chooses not chooses
he naturally makes the decision
to sacrifice the romantic relationship
with the woman
in in further pursuit of this chaos
of this chaotic pursuit of excellence
and it feel that doesn't feel like a
deliberate decision it feels like a
giant
mess of like an emotional mess where
you're just like
kind of like a fish swimming against
stream just like
it you let go of all the things
that convention says you should
appreciate
you you throw away the possibility of a
stable life of a comfortable life of uh
uh what society says is a meaningful
life
and just pursue this crazy thing full of
seeming toxicity with crazy people
surrounding you
i don't know so i don't know what the
right decision is like part of my brain
says you should stay with the girl
uh that instructor that's making
you
uh that's pushing you to to places where
it's like
that are destructive potentially
destructive like could lead to suicide
could lead you to um completely
uh
fail or fail on your pursuit
of excellence or destroy the possibility
to destroy the dream
the passion or pursuit of the thing that
you've always dreamed for in that case
is drumming
i don't know i'm on many minds there
like what is the right thing to do
so my first two thoughts are number one
convention
what is convention it's like a some laid
out
path some linear progression of the way
your life is supposed to go
like you know that someone can draw a
picture of at the end that shit's
that first of all it's just boring and
whatever
and it's it's i don't want to say that
it's cowardly because it isn't cowardly
but for someone who's not conventional
to not be non-conventional
is cowardly to get sucked into the
convention that's first
second of all i believe
that scene in the diner in that movie
where he tells her yeah you're in my way
because
i'm gonna want to be with you or you're
going to want me to be going out to
dinner with you and i know i should be
practicing or i know i should be
training
and ultimately i'm going to make i'm
either going to feel bad about not being
with you
by training or i'm going to skip the
training to be with you and neither one
is right
the whole thing that they don't mention
in that is that that's the wrong girl
that's the wrong girl
the right girl is a gangster the right
girl says
oh you you you've practiced tonight i'll
leave you a sandwich and some milk so
that you can
you know uh outside the door uh let me
know when you're done or you have some
like free time
like the right girl compliments that
she's not an impediment
in any way even if what you want to do
is
be with her so much that you're putting
the drums down you're putting the bass
down or you're picking up the pizza or
you're not going to training like
that girl without even telling you why
she's making decisions
is making decisions to help you achieve
your goal
now that might sound like some sort of
like chauvinistic king of the castle
type like where everyone should
cater to you
but the fact of the matter is uh
that person is a compliment to your life
and helping you do your thing
and in your own way you're helping them
to achieve whatever their goals are also
it's uncommon that you have two people
under the same roof
striving to be unbelievably excellent in
one small area it's not impossible but
it's uncommon
like relationships have to be like
binary systems like two stars
like the gravitational pull is what
keeps you together and circling around
one another right
and and you know one is bigger than the
other and they'll fluctuate and you know
the stars will get bigger and they'll
get smaller and they're contract
based on positioning and you know
composition
that that's the way a relationship
should be not an asteroid coming in
to disrupt you know your the the surface
of your planet
yeah it's a binary system it's a
compliment that girl was the wrong girl
for him
so you shouldn't uh like the big
unconventional dreams
should not be adjusted to fit into this
world because i mean there's a part of
me that's like full of salt out well
maybe you're just a dick
maybe maybe who cares
so first of all who cares
this is uh by the by the way somebody
who's uh
you have you have recently gotten well
recently
in the span of the history of the
universe is recently you got into a
relationship but you haven't always
you have not felt the need to be
in the relationship just because you're
supposed to by society's kind of
momentum if you i think that if you
really want anything
you've got to be prepared fully to be
the exact opposite
if you're a person who's looking for a
relationship the only way you're going
to get in an awesome relationship is by
being comfortable being
alone yeah because that's the risk if
you're a person who's driven by money
you've got to be comfortable being
totally poor
because that's the risk right and when
you're when
when you're when you're constantly
hedging your bets you're never
all in you're never all in on the thing
you're trying to do
um a relationship has to complement your
life you can't say
it's okay to want to be in a
relationship but you can't want to be in
a relationship so bad
that you take someone in who fits the
suit and it's like oh
our schedules kind of work out you live
near me and this and the other thing
because the logistics of a relationship
are not always perfect
it's what matters is when the two people
are together that's the perfect part
of it and
it's great to want to meet people and
say
if we meet and some sort of a
relationship develops
i'm willing to run with it but i'm not
meeting you hoping a relationship
develops
i think you kind of put the cart before
the horse in a lot of those
situations it's like when guys meet like
no guy goes out and is like i'm looking
for a bro
right nobody does that you go to the gym
and you run into a bunch of dudes and
the next thing you know someone's cool
and they want to talk about fighting
and you're shotgun and beers and
all of a sudden you've got a bro yeah
and that's how it works it works the
same
same way with what's the shotgun and
beers um i'll show you after this you
poke a hole in the bottom and you open
the top
yeah yeah this is the problem with
america
drink vodka like a man okay now don't
poke holes in beers
this is the problem with the frat
culture they don't really know how to
drink they think they know how to drink
they don't know how to drink
you